[Musique]
en famille ou entre amis
en groupe ou en solitaire quand viennent
les beaux jours les vélos route du
centre Val de Loire deviennent le
terrain de jeu des vacances
c'est la liberté on est à l'air libre
pas dans une cage de plastique ni de
métal en France la région et la première
destination de tourisme à vélo ces
dernières années les offres se sont
multipliées autour des itinéraires
cyclables de la Loire et de ses châteaux
on a acheté 12 vélos en 2015 ou 2016 je
crois aujourd'hui on en a on en a
quasiment 800 donc c'est assez
révélateur de cette croissance un
tourisme plus respectueux de
l'environnement autour duquel certains
départements souhaitent orienter leur
économie la découverte du territoire à
vélo en particulier c'est effectivement
devenu une priorité en termes de
structuration du développement
touristique
[Musique]
au camping et Immo 18 mois donne ses
premiers coups de accompagné de
Thomas son papa
et nous on est parti d'ici pendant ce
temps la grande soeur M6 5 ans et Annie
c'est la maman
un petit peu corroyer parce qu'on fait
ça aujourd'hui prépare le programme du
jour
[Musique]
originaire de région parisienne ils sont
partis de Baule près d'Orléans pour
suivre l'itinéraire de la Loire à vélo
mais en 5 jours la famille n'a pas couru
qu'une centaine de kilomètres
c'est maximum deux heures par jour en
fait le vélo donc on fait on fait on
fait doucement et on visite des trucs on
s'arrête à toutes les aires de jeux
on s'arrête pour changer toutes les
couches pour manger pour goûter on
s'arrête tout le temps
beaucoup de farine et un petit peu de
vélo
midi vient de sonner
c'est parti la famille se met tout juste
en route pour une balade de 25 km
[Musique]
ils espèrent atteindre Nantes dans
quelques jours mais pour eux l'essentiel
est de prendre son temps
[Musique]
voyagez à vélo pour mieux profiter du
paysage et respecter la nature
environnante c'est ce qu'on appelle le
slotourisme une pratique à laquelle
Thomas et anissaient sont attachés
on dirait un side-car
c'est un choix pour voyager léger pour
voyager effectivement pour limiter notre
empreinte carbone
on a commencé ces démarches là il y a
5-6 ans déjà à peu près et c'est vrai
qu'avec les enfants on est parti on est
plutôt parti en vélo puisque la
randonnée ça a été un peu plus compliqué
on faisait plutôt de la randonnée
auparavant et
donc là le vélo bah ça c'est un choix
qui s'est imposé
et puis là on évolue puisque maintenant
on est passé sur l'électrique
assistance électrique alors qu'avant
c'est même voyage sans électric et là
c'était c'était difficile quand même il
consomme des produits locaux privilégie
le camping ou le bivouac et ont décidé
de s'affranchir de la voiture ou de
l'avion pour les vacances
ce tourisme est correspondable fait de
plus en plus d'adeptes
à Blois ces deux cousines s'apprêtent à
prendre la route direction Amboise
pour l'antivol vous avez eu le code
c'est tout bon et est-ce que la selle
vous convient au niveau de la hauteur
elles viennent de Toulouse et ont décidé
de rester en France pour les congés
c'est mieux que de partir à l'autre bout
du monde en avion l'emprunte écologique
elle est quand même pas la même c'est
clair et puis enfin oui ça fait un peu
partie d'une démarche générale de moi me
dire qu'il y a aussi des très belles
choses à voir en France et qu'on n'est
pas obligé de partir loin pour pour
profiter de ses vacances merci beaucoup
bonne journée au revoir
et elles sont loin d'être les seules la
haute saison débute et ici l'activité
bat son plein
[Musique]
il a créé son entreprise en 2013 sur la
base d'un tourisme plus respectueux de
l'environnement ces vélos sont conçus et
assemblés en France et pour attirer une
nouvelle clientèle il propose des
séjours sur mesure avec réservation
d'hôtels et transport de bagages
c'est important et y compris dans le cas
du développement de l'entreprise au
niveau de son développement économique
que n'importe qui puisse se dire tiens
les vacances à vélo ça doit être
chouette et que ce soit pas réservé
effectivement à des militants à des gens
qui font du vélo depuis toujours et tous
les jours cela n'ont pas besoin d'être
convaincu et donc notre boulot c'est de
rendre les choses aussi faciles que
possible pour ses clients pour qui c'est
quelque chose de nouveau et donc de
transférer les bagages de proposer des
des vélos hyper fiables de
d'apporter des services autour de toutes
ces prestations d'assistance et autres
pour que les vacances à vélo ça devienne
accessible au plus grand nombre que ce
soit au niveau économique au niveau des
sensibilités
[Musique]
ouvrir le cyclotourisme à un public plus
large un potentiel exploité en centre
Val de Loire depuis une dizaine d'années
[Musique]
à 40 km au sud de Bourges au pied de
l'abbaye de Noirlac
une nouvelle piste cyclable est en train
de sortir de terre
[Musique]
on mettra peut-être autour de la mare le
moment de rue là aussi un petit
garde-corps pour pour symboliser la main
et on disposera une une plaque
explicative de ce que c'est que cette
marque à quoi elle sert etc
et le reliera le monument à l'itinéraire
du canal de Berry à vélo 2 km à travers
une zone
naturellement du tronçon n'a pas été
choisi au hasard
qui est mélangé quasiment pour le
stabiliser ça va se fondre dans le décor
naturel
le rapport une couche noire au milieu de
la verdure il ne s'agit pas d'un simple
choix esthétique car le projet se veut
exemplaire du point de vue
environnemental
c'est pas l'enlever c'est pas du béton
et c'est pas non plus un simple
stabilisé
on est dans un espace naturel sensible
on est à proximité du zones humide donc
là le choix était de faire un stabilisé
renforcé donc une formule particulière
qui permet d'avoir un revêtement qui non
seulement s'intègre bien dans la nature
mais en plus à la particularité de
perméable et donc il permet
effectivement d'infiltrer mieux les eaux
lorsqu'il y a effectivement des
intempéries
en matière d'aménagement et de
slotourisme le Cher fait partie des
pionniers dans la région
[Musique]
en plus des itinéraires déjà existants
ici envers sur la carte trois nouveaux
tronçons cyclables en jaune sont en
cours de réalisation en bleu les
aménagements encore à l'étude
dans son schéma de développement
touristique décidé pour la période
2023-2028 le département accorde une
place essentielle aux mobilité douce le
Cher veut surfer sur le succès du
cyclotourisme en s'appuyant sur ses
qualités
nous n'avons pas la montagne nous
n'avons pas la mer mais nous avons nos
campagnes et nous construisons autour de
notre patrimoine naturel et culturel
nous ne souhaitons pas des volumes
importants de touristes nous souhaitons
qu'ils augmentent leur fréquentation
qu'il reste plus longtemps sur notre
territoire pour nous c'est le tourisme
durable que l'on met en avant
symbole également d'un tourisme durable
s'échapper à vélo sans s'éloigner de
chez soi
nous sommes un samedi après-midi à
Olivet ce groupe se prépare à partir
pour une balade organisée par une
association locale
la plupart des participants habitent les
alentours et ce jour-là ils ont un guide
s'il vous plaît Michel Chantereau
[Musique]
c'est parti pour une dizaine de
kilomètres dans le cadre champêtre de la
périphérie d'Orléans
[Musique]
un milieu riche de sa faune et de sa
flore sauvage
avec vous c'est faire un peu une ce
qu'on appelle une lecture de paysage
c'est un peu de comprendre les paysages
qui nous entourent plein de petites
points entre deux coups de un
cours de botanique s'impose et Michel
enca connaît un rayon il est naturaliste
alors là il y a les ronces là il y a des
rangs incontestables quel est le rôle
des ronces dans les dans les successions
des végétaux est-ce que vous avez une
idée ça joue un rôle essentiel parce que
ça prépare le terrain pour les jeunes
arbres voilà
sensibiliser à l'écologie c'est
l'objectif recherché souvent on a
utilisé le cognassier très souvent et
donc moi c'est important de dédramatiser
ce que c'est que la ronce la friche et
les plantes qui piquent et puis tout à
l'heure on fera un arrêt pour parler du
lierre et des gens qui rachelières qui
coupent bon c'est parfaitement
c'est c'est inutile au mieux stupide au
pire on peut dire derrière il y a une
idée de préservation effectivement de
compréhension et de préservation mieux
comprendre pour mieux protéger pourquoi
ce type d'événement a lieu deux fois par
an Michel et son association défendent
un tourisme local car jusqu'à présent
beaucoup de participants n'avaient pas
forcément connaissance du patrimoine
naturel autour d'eux le lierre ne tue
pas l'arme c'est sûr je suis surprise de
trouver de la verdure alors que j'ai de
la famille dans le coin et c'est plutôt
du métaux du goudron donc là je suis
très surprise si vous observez bien dans
les hauteurs vous verrez que le lierre
il ne va pas dans le houpier ça ne va
pas dans les petites branches avec les
feuilles déjà d'Olivier qui ne sont
jamais venus ici donc ça leur fait
découvrir des lieux sans pour cela
d'apprendre la voiture par exemple
[Musique]
allié pédagogique et activité physique
avec un guide nature
rouler sans hâte au bord des cours d'eau
de notre région
admirer ces paysages sa biodiversité
aujourd'hui
22 millions de Français déclarent faire
du cyclotourisme pendant leurs vacances
l'idée de voyager autrement fait son
chemin
en disant le vélo est même devenu la
première pratique itinérance touristique